this is so crazy and I'm still trying to
keep up with twice a week posting or
also being in college 2019 wasn't a
great year for you Olivia Jade being a
teenager who is ready for college is
tough enough but then the news of your
parents is bad decision hit it's not
clear how much you knew about the
admissions scandal but you were just a
kid it wasn't your fault that didn't
stop the haters on the internet though
we just wish they realized that there's
a lot more to you than that bad press we
really admire how you've overcome this
setback and continued to do what you do
best
part of me is like should I come back to
YouTube right now
Olivia Jade has been a successful hair
and makeup youtuber for quite a while so
when the media found out about the
College Admission scandal the internet
went crazy but we are here to tell you
everything you need to know about Olivia
Jade Olivia Jade joined YouTube on June
19 2014 she had a passion for hair and
beauty and she decided to share it with
the world
[Music]
her videos were relatable which made her
really popular among teen girls even
though her parents are famous she really
came across like a friend
she also vlogged about other aspects of
her life she posted lots of content with
her mom Lori Lachlan it's clear that
these two are very close the mom and
daughter videos were always a hit and it
helped to pull an even more subscribers
Olivia lives a glamorous life which
appealed to her audience but she was
always down to earth Olivia has nearly 2
million subscribers on YouTube it's
mostly hair and makeup but she also
talks about fashion her life and even
does YouTube challenges her mom might be
an actress but Olivia takes after her
designer father the success of her
YouTube channel led to Olivia being a
popular social media influencer thank
you guys so much for watching my morning
routine and I love you guys also don't
forget to Like comment most of Olivia's
fans are Jenn's e-girls the younger
generation might not be familiar with
her parents but everyone else's Olivia's
mom is Lori Laughlin Lori is best known
for her time on the sitcom full house
she played Aunt Becky from 1988 until
1995
come on little froggie mama and she
reprised her role on fuller house a few
years late
Laurie became a TV star after that she
usually played the cool but caring mom
or aunt bigger and it seems like that
persona carried over into her real life
Laurie also starred in shows like summer
land and the 2008 reboot of 90210 most
recently she was on what calls the heart
Olivia's dad is the fashion designer his
name is Massimo Janu II fans of Target
will recognize him from his brand
massimo his stylish but affordable
clothes and shoes have been in target
stores for years Massimo and Lori have
been married since 1997 they have an
older daughter named Isabella Olivia is
the youngest of their two girls if
you're a youtube star or any sort of
entrepreneur it's important to take
risks however those risks should never
affect your safety while driving olivia
hasn't always made the best decisions in
her videos sometimes she films herself
singing and dancing while she's behind
the wheel I'm obsessed with Queen it's
actually an issue that's super dangerous
in 2017 she was filming a vlog in her
car she was on her way to the salon and
she was dancing and singing while she
was at a red light she was hit from
behind by a truck she blasted the driver
for not paying attention and begged for
people to always be aware while driving
but fans were quick to point out the
irony in that situation she had not been
paying attention at all while she was
driving Olivia apologized and said that
she realized that it could have been her
that hit someone she promised to never
film or use her phone while driving ever
again we really hope that she learned
that lesson because unsafe driving is no
joke first a little car accident I'm
okay I'm a little bit sore in my head
hurts a tiny bit
fans of Olivia's makeup videos knows
that she loves good quality makeup and
Sephora has always been one of her
favorites so the first shade I'm going
to show you guys from the spore
collection of creamy lip stains is
Sephora stores are found all over North
America they carry many different brands
of makeup Sephora often partners with
celebrities and social media influencers
in 2018 Sephora partnered with Olivia
Jade to make a new line of cosmetics she
worked with them to create a line of
color palettes she even posted a video
of the creation and selection process
for the colors people loved the products
and plenty of other makeup youtubers
posted reviews the line launched in
December of 2018 but the success was
short-lived after the college scandal
broke people were upset at Sephora for
their partnership with Olivia they ended
up cancelling their deal and pulling her
products from their store almost
overnight
it was a huge setback for Olivia I'm
sorry in early 2019 there were reports
of a bunch of celebrities who had bribed
colleges to get their kids admitted Lori
Laughlin was one of the biggest names in
the scandal but it looks like Olivia
might have accidentally caused the
backlash question about college and I
said like oh I'm not excited to do this
before she went to college she had
tweeted that school was hard because she
didn't care about learning but then she
got into the University of Southern
California USC is a prestigious school
so this didn't match up she posted a
video about how she was feeling about
college she said she didn't really care
about the school part but that she
wanted to experience game days in
college parties she even missed the
first week of school for a vacation in
Fiji yeah not the best look people were
put to comment on her attitude about
school because there are tons of people
who really want an education from USC
but Olivia loves a good party when her
parents were arrested
she was actually partying on a yacht
with a friend really disappointed in
myself I'm not here to make excuses or
whatever
no matter what Olivia thought about
school she was just a kid when all this
happened she might be a young adult now
but her parents are really the ones
responsible in early 2019 a huge
investigation broke about college
admissions
it appeared that many wealthy people
including celebrities had helped if
their children get admitted to college
many of these kids were admitted as
athletes since they didn't have the
grades to get in but none of these kids
actually played sports olivia was
admitted to USC as a member of the crew
team but she had never competed in
rowing at all none of her days in the
life videos mentioned it her parents
sent in a couple of stage two photos of
her rowing but USC didn't verify it at
all very studious then even more came to
light
Lori Lachlan and massimo de nuit had
paid over half a million dollars in
bribes to get Olivia into USC this was
highly illegal they were arrested and
got out on a million dollar bond
both Lori and Massimo plead not guilty
this means they could face up to 50
years in prison each it's unlikely that
they'll get the maximum sentence but
jail time is still on the table
what is Olivia Jade doing these days
keep watching to find out legal battles
are tricky when there's an ongoing
investigation in trial the people
involved can't talk about it anything
going on right now there's no doubt that
Lori and Massimo we're just trying to
help their daughter but in the end they
just ended up hurting her people got
really nasty on social media and YouTube
Olivia has not been investigated since
she was just a teenager it's unclear how
much she actually knew about what her
parents were doing but people on the
internet have continued to blame her I
try and not read the comments they
called her terrible names and wished
horrible things on her she actually had
to disable comments on all of her
accounts Olivia didn't post on social
media for several months she also took a
long hiatus from YouTube although there
was nothing legal stopping her from
doing tutorials she did make a video for
nearly nine months because I want to
come back these days there are a bunch
of celebrities who are just social media
influencers a social-media influencer
has a lot of followers
they often get sponsorships from
companies which helps those companies
advertise influencers can make several
thousand dollars from a single post but
the problem with being an influencer is
how easy it is to lose everything
Olivia's YouTube success enabled her to
become a social-media influencer she had
a ton of brand partnerships in addition
to Sephora she worked with Amazon smiled
direct Club Tresemme and Marc Jacobs she
wrapped a Dolce & Gabbana and Clinique
she even had her own clothing line with
princess Polly that's just a few of the
companies that she worked with
today Amazon is coming to shoot some of
my room Amazon paid for everything that
she decorated her dorm with at USC
of course she's the daughter of two
famous people so she could afford her
own stuff but that's the glorious life
of an influencer thanks to her videos
and social media posts olivia is worth a
million dollars
but since the scandal broke most of
these companies have dropped their
partnerships with her this is the
greatest investment it's not just
Olivia's college application that had a
scandal it's also an application for
trademark with the US government shortly
before the admission scandal broke
Olivia had announced her old brand of
makeup she wanted to trademark the
company makeup is such a strong passion
of mine doing that requires a formal
application with the US government and
everything has to be in perfect order
but the government rejected her
application she had so many grammatical
errors that were mostly missing
punctuation marks there was also not
enough detail about the moisturiser and
concealer did she fill it out herself if
she hired an attorney to do it we hope
they knew better eventually she
submitted a corrected application and it
was accepted
Olivia is no longer enrolled at the
University of Southern California in
August 2019 an anonymous source told et
that she was not going back they also
said that she never wanted to attend USC
in the first place
Olivia knows it's not the place for her
a couple of weeks later the USC
Registrar confirmed that Olivia and her
sister Isabella are not enrolled at all
olivia has stayed out of the media since
then she returned to youtube in December
of 2019 a couple of weeks later she
posted a makeup tutorial as of this
video she hasn't posted anything since
she is actively posting on Instagram she
posted a photo with her boyfriend
Jackson on Valentine's Day we know it's
going to be hard work to rebuild her
image but olivia is well on her way
who's your favorite social media
influencer let us know in the comments
thanks for watching and don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to the
things for more great content see you
next time
you